hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the air things masters this is
the second match uh and the players are
the same it's ianni pomeshi versus
magnus carlson yesterday was the first
uh match ended in a draw all four games
were drawn after a day of incredibly
fighting chess and now we are starting
off with the first game of the second
match it's again uh really an incredible
game uh some chances were missed but you
guys are here to rectify that so let's
check it out nipple with the white
pieces opens with e4 a c5 by magnus
going for the sicilian defense knight f3
we have knight to c6 and again bishop to
b5 going for the niece medina of a
rossolimo attack we have g6 magnus goes
for his fiance variation
and now castles bishop to g7 we have d3
and d6 so nothing new uh for the moment
uh and now uh the early e5 this is uh
perfectly fine the knight on c6 is
pinned so d captures on e5 we have
bishop captures on c6 with check b
captures and now rook to e1 putting
pressure on the e5 pawn queen to c7
defending and not knight to a3 so you
can see
it's a very nice setup as the
uh c pawn is now doubled there is no
b-pawn so once this knight comes to c4
there is no b-pawn or d-pawn to kick it
away from c4 it will be an excellent
square for this knight so knight f6
knight captures an e5 grabbing back the
pawn and now knight to d5 opening up an
attack on the knight here so knight ate
the c4 now nicely defending the knight
on e5 so now you have two excellently
placed knights and here uh magnus just
castles and there are uh
well the position has been reached
before uh but the move nipple plays the
h3 move is a new one uh so already as of
move 12 we have a completely new game so
here after h3 uh we have bishop to a6
putting pressure on the knight here so
magnus might have some ideas of
capturing and doubling up nipples c
pawns as well but that also means giving
up the bishop pair so here queen e2
nipple says all right you can capture
here uh but um
that would actually be very bad because
if bishop captures we're gonna capture
with the pawn challenge the knight here
and once the knight moves we're gonna
play bishop to f4 and this is just a
beautiful beautiful position for white
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries once the queen moves rook a
to d1 white completed development and
just has a
spectacular position so instead magnus
plays f6 uh for the moment it seems a
bit weakening but you are getting rid of
the knight from this beautiful square
and then you will advance this pawn to
e5 so knight back to f3 with e5 and now
bishop to e3 continuing development and
offering the bishop for a knight which
magnus happily accepts uh knight
captures an e3 and now queen captures an
e3 still not worried about this capture
obviously uh nipple
had this position already somewhere and
he knows that it is good for him even
though it's the best move recommended by
the engine but magnus agrees with nipple
so rook after e8 just continuing
development now knight f to d2 and now
nipple wants to play knight to b3 and
put pressure on this c5 pawn and magnus
will have to trade on c4
so queen to e7 adding a defender to the
c5 pawn and now uh knight to b3 here in
nepal continues with his plan of going
after the c5 pawn when maybe rook to e2
followed by rook a to e1 putting
pressure along this e file uh could be
uh maybe a better way to go but okay
it's a rapid game knights to b3 and now
magnus trades on c4 doubles up nipple
spawns captures captures and now a
bishop to f8 we have to keep an eye on
this pawn here and now it looks a bit
clunky for black but magnus is preparing
f5 e4 and there's not much nipple can do
about this so rook 8 to d1 grabbing the
open d file and magnus advances the pawn
to f5 there's no need to rush with rook
8 28 as there are no squares that this
rook can go to so
white cannot infiltrate here rook to d2
nipple prepares to double up on the d
file and now rook a to d8 we have rookie
to d1 and magnus advances the pawn to e4
and now if you could advance those pawns
a little bit further it will be
extremely dangerous for white
and uh it's interesting uh there's this
a very cool line rook captures rook
capture so rook captures queen captures
and now knight captures on c5 of course
you can win a pawn here
but you can also blunder the game here
because now just queen d1 check king h2
and you bring the queen back to d6 with
check and there goes the knight so
instead after e4 that we have c3 and now
magnus trades rook captures on e2 queen
captures on d2 and now queen the e5
grabbing more space centralizing the
queen uh this always feels great when
you can do that sometimes when you don't
know what to play and you have an option
to centralize your queen uh more often
than not it is the strongest move to be
made so here queen e5 and now knight to
a5 going after the undefended c6 pawn so
magnus defends it rook to e6 it's also a
very nice active move with the rook not
only defending but also preparing rook
d6 in some lines so here g3 by nepo
and now magnus went into a deep thing
some four minutes were spent here on
this move because there's quite a lot to
consider
how do you put more pressure on
on white's position here because you can
feel that black is better here but how
do you do it one way to do it is to try
and sacrifice the g5 pawn uh but let's
let's see what happens queen captures on
g5 we're going to play rook g6 and i'll
put insane pressure here on the g3 pawn
f4 is coming next the problem is there's
nine captures on c6 attacking our queen
and after queen to c7 we can even play
queen captures on f5 and give up the
knight and after queen captures with
something like rook to d8 and this will
be uh well it will be very hard for for
black to get out of this uh of course
white is not winning or anything it's um
it's uh it's an equal position
uh but uh quite a quite an exotic one
for example rook f6 queen g5 check we
can go rogue back queen f5 and so on uh
another thing after g3 there's the very
very interesting h5 and now uh what do
you what do you do here well of course
we want to play we want to continue
pushing so let's say queen g5 now comes
bishop e7 kicks away the queen queen f4
and now we could see a trade que here or
magnus could maybe uh put the queen
somewhere else but probably a trade
captures captures and now bishop to d6
and once everything gets traded off for
example knight captures in c6 bishop
captures f4 knight captures on a7 rook
a6 going after the a2 pawn knight will
move somewhere will capture us on a2 we
would get a decent game
where black is much better as there is
play on both sides of the board it's a
bishop against the knight plus
a lot of these pawns are very weak so
the these are the options but magnus
goes uh
for a third one so not g5 right away not
h5 he goes for rook to d6 he wants to uh
force the queen away from the d file uh
and then uh will tr trade off uh the the
remaining rook so here uh we have queen
to e2 rook captures on d1 with check
queen captures and now e3 that's the
idea so what can nipple do to defend
this he plays queen to e2 which is uh
definitely the way to go now if magnus
trades here just king captures and
there's no really
a fun active move for black there's not
all that much uh here in the position so
instead magnus brings the bishop in
bishop to h6 and now nipple very quickly
just plays knight to b3 there is time
for this as uh well black does not have
all that many threats so here magnus
plays f4 continues pushing and now g
captures on f4 bishop captures f
captures on e3 bishop captures and king
to g2 so magnus was able to bust open uh
nipples defenses uh now how can he
continue well he starts by improving the
position of his king putting it to a
little bit of a safer square so king g7
now comes queen f3 now we will put
pressure on this c6 pawn and hope that
black can't do really anything to the
white king bishop to g5 now magnus wants
to infiltrate with the bishop this way
knight the eighth i'm going after the c6
spawn and now bishop to h4 so here uh
cutting off a lot of squares away from
from the white king knight captures on
c6 attacking the queen here grabbing the
pawn and now queen to g5 with check
going after that
d2 square another way to do it would be
just queen d6 put pressure on the knight
and also go for the d to square so here
uh uh we have king to h2 a safer a safer
thing would be something like queen g4
and after queen to d to check king of
three but uh who who does this it's it's
incredibly weird to play like this so
instead after queen g5 we have king to
h2 and now queen to d2 with check queen
to g2 and now queen f4 check so now will
we see a repetition well king h1 was
played queen to c1 check king to h2 and
queen to f4 with check and now
after king to h1 there is a move that
allows magnus to win this game but it's
incredibly difficult to find so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find this possibly missed chance while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting
this incredible idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show uh
it is not uh queen anywhere else uh it's
queen to e3 that's the move you have to
have to find and this is uh well uh this
is now game over for white and the
problem is uh what can white to do well
you can't really move the queen all that
much and you can't to deliver any checks
to the black king so what you can do is
play something like a4 or knight
captures on a7 both moves are very
useful for white now we play h5 and
again what can white do white will go
back now we play bishop to g5 we want to
put the bishop on f4 and take away the
h2 square from the king and once white
starts pushing a4 or b4 it doesn't
really matter white's moves are pretty
much
whatever white plays black's moves will
be the same so here bishop f4 a5 we're
gonna play queen to e1 with check and
now after queen g1 we're gonna play
queen to e2 and now uh well there are
two options here really you could start
advancing the pawn but if you advance
the pawn then bishop to e3 attacks the
queen and now
well that's just it pretty much you
either uh give up the back rank or you
give up the uh the control of this
diagonal so what can you do here queen
to g2 just queen e1 check king h2 and
the bishop f4 check that's the plan no
more squares for the black king you have
to give up the queen and then you get
checkmated and another thing instead of
this a6 move if we don't play that we
could play queen to g2 right away but
again it doesn't help queen to d3 first
and now after white makes any move now
we play bishop to e3 this is also a very
nice
pattern that uh well can come in very
handy if you know it by heart and after
let's say a7 queen to d1 check king the
h2 and now bishop to f4 check everything
is cut off from the black king you have
to play queen g3 and now we go in with
our own queen queen d2 checking each one
and bishop captures and g3 and of course
you get mated on the next move so this
is what's happening but um of course
magnus says a minute on the clock and
there is no time to spot queen e3 or
calculate it he plays a6 uh takes care
of his his pawn uh and it makes sense if
you're not sure about queen e3 or if you
you're not thinking about it then you
are of course afraid of knight captures
on a7 those pawns are uh going to start
marching forward so here we have queen
to e2
now trying to get uh
into the position but okay for the
moment uh you don't have queen e7 and
you don't have queen e5 okay you can
play queen e5 and trade queens but
magnus first place queen c1 check king
h2 queen f4 check king to h1 and queen
to c1 check and here of course after
king h2 and queen f4 we have king to h1
and he was in this position on rule 46
that the players agree to a draw or
rather it was a draw by threefold
repetition
uh so really incredible start to to day
two uh much like yesterday there was a
lot of action uh some chances were
missed but in the end the game again
ends in a draw uh so
next game uh magnets will have the white
pieces and we'll see uh what will happen
then uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it really a wild one uh i
would like to thank cypher kicks leo
joel bourne uh james o'toole uh john
cousins and nikita nicholas for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
rest of the match uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day